Pacific Rim 2 was just announced with
John boyega did you see that what do you
think of that I'm very excited about it
you know I think what's interesting is
he from what I read and I'm not involved
in it in any way I'm well dead is he's
playing he's playing addresses son it's
a kind of nice to see like a big-time
jump where all of us are kind of gone
and the next generation has to deal with
the same thing and the kind of advanced
systems you're gonna see on a Jaeger of
another generations technology that's
really exciting obviously know Chuck in
Pacific Rim to a career as in ski is
currently taking on Warcraft a huge
honor considering Robert is a longtime
gamer you were like at one time what
10th in the world I was in the it's very
complicated ranking system but I ranked
regularly in the if we were in a top 100
guild and I was one of the better of my
class in the world yeah but it was Jamie
Lee Curtis who upstaged us all at the
premiere I mean she's not even in the
movie did you see Jamie Lee Curtis I
just saw Jamie Kennedy I'm not blow your
person's like is that Jamie Lee Curtis
then is that Jamie Lee Curtis as a or a
very surreal image